[Music]
i'd like to discuss something that
happened very recently we were doing a
segment of the podcast where i talked to
fans people all around the world they
drop when do they drop thursdays but we
had this very strange moment we were
talking to a woman from westerly rhode
island named sarah who's an optometrist
we were laughing about a bunch of
different things and then i just said
what's the worst
thing you've seen you know ailment
you've seen come into your office
obviously mostly it's fitting
prescriptions but what's the worst does
anyone ever come in with an injury and
she said oh yeah a guy came in
and his chicken had attacked him and uh
poked into his eye
and out of nowhere do you remember this
sona out of suddenly yeah it's the
craziest thing on cue on cue
yeah matt gourley says oh yeah i have a
relative and then you gave this crazy
name that sounds made up
and it's so crazy that i wrote it down
on my desk and it's still here written
on my desk
elmer elmsworth gourley ellsworth
ellsworth oh i'm sorry i'm sorry don't
want to mess up ellsworth yeah so we're
talking to this woman and she mentions
something insane because she's an
optometrist and she says yeah one guy
came in and his chicken had attacked him
and pecked his eye and immediately
as if it were nothing gurley just says
oh yeah i had a a relative a great great
grandfather named elmer ellsworth
gourley whose eye was pecked out by a
chicken and then he immediately holds up
a photo yeah of this guy from 1880 who's
missing an eye and he's got a big
mustache beautiful mustache and you had
the picture ready to go yeah uh this was
not set up this was not a uh in any way
we didn't do any research we didn't know
anything about this it was totally
random that this woman sarah mentioned
this and you have an effing
picture
of elmer ellsworth gurley missing an eye
ready to go how is that possible i've
just been carrying it around waiting for
the chance to bring it up finally today
that's exactly what it looked like i
pictured you you go to lectures you go
to restaurants you always have the
picture ready to go you're always ready
for someone to say well that puts me in
mind at the time someone got their eye
picked up by a chicken and you leap up
and you say i too sir know of such a man
his name be elmer ellsworth gourley and
here is his visage and you hold up a
picture
there's never so many times when someone
said chicken and he's perked up ready to
go anywhere else never or or else he's
somewhere random and he's got his
picture ready to go and someone says
i'll never forget the time my
great-great-grandfather had his eye
pecked out and you're like here we go
bye
an owl
you slowly sink back into your seat and
jam
the wrinkled photo of elmer ellsworth
gourley back into your jacket there's a
usual suspect's aspect to this where if
you listen back to the podcast you
wouldn't know it because it never got
there but i'm always bringing up
chickens in my eyes yeah sure yeah
hoping that you can get you know jessica
alba and she's like wait what who's this
guy talking now i thought i was talking
to conan just i'm curious if you have an
eye for the chicken if you know what i
mean don't you think chickens are so
dangerous hey wait a minute
i'm i'm determined like any good
reporter i must find out why gorilla did
you have that picture ready to go so so
hesitant to tell you of all people
because i just feel like you're never
gonna let me live this down but i can't
wait okay i have a band and i have a
song about this man called eyesore and
i'm working on a video where i'm doing
this little old 70s computer that does a
printout of the visuals and it scrolls
along and i just know i'm in for it once
i've told you that and it's out now oh
my god
i am a very a man who's starving to
death and i've been crawling i'm
crawling through the desert i know oh
and i just i just came upon a large
thanksgiving a large fresh thanksgiving
meal
on a table with white linen and one
chair
and there's a little card there that
says mr o'brien and i'm i am gonna chow
down you have a ban what's the ban it's
called town land and what do you play in
the band i'm guessing guitar i play
guitar yeah okay and you wrote a song
about your ancestor what is he your
great-great-grandfather that's right
yeah and his name say it again elmer
ellsworth gourley and you wrote a song
about this man called eyesore yeah
because
i guess it's funny to you that he lost
denial well tragedy plus time
[Laughter]
it is true it is true uh it's been a
while how does the song go can you tell
us any of the lyrics oh god
i mean let me let me think this is
delicious this is succulent
soda taste some of this girly discomfort
isn't it delicious
it is quite tasty i'm not gonna lie i
usually don't like siding with you but
this is very delicious oh my god
i couldn't have another bite or could i
i know you you'll be eating on this for
years do you does the song recreate the
accident is it like you know the song is
talking about
elmer ellsworth gourley and then you
hear
that
and then you hear my eye my eye
it's all chicken sounds do you remember
that jingle bell song done by dogs yup
okay you seem hesitant to tell us too
much more about the song i'm hesitant
about everything right now will this be
available when will people get to uh
maybe go online and listen to your band
what's the name again of your band
please townland townland metallica was
taken
yes it's out february 22nd and the album
is called honey on the hi-fi can we see
the photo again matt can you show it to
us yeah show it to us again
okay oh wow that looks like toby mcguire
with a kurt russell mustache from
tombstone i mean i'm not going to lie
he's he's a looker he's except those
both those actors you referenced though
had both their eyes
i think he was a teacher a one-eyed
teacher i mean i'm not if he was my
teacher i'd be like hello mr gourley
yeah
he was a good-looking guy yeah he's
dapper huh he's pretty dapper although
of course absolutely
absolutely no depth perception so look
at him yeah that's the problem when
you've got one eye there's just he'd go
to put the wedding ring on you
you'd be like no you've got six more
feet to go before you hit my finger oh
god this is uh did he ever opt for a
glass eye or a prosthetic i don't know
he said he probably didn't have one in
this photo i think back then they just
used what was it they put whatever was
available in there a marble you know or
what like an inkwell or sometimes
sometimes the hub of a wagon wheel they
just jammed whatever was in there and uh
people they'd go into a bar and people
were like are you looking at me no no
that's a wagon wheel in my left socket
it's still a hundred years before they
come up with the old glass eye
prosthetic did he wear an eye patch i
you know i've never seen a picture of
him with an eye patch i would wear an
do you know why the chicken attacked him
uh i think it happened when he was a boy
so maybe he was just playing with the
chicken and mike the only thing i've
been told by my grandpa was a quote
overzealous rooster packed his eye out
when he was
is that one of the lines in the song
no do you want any help with any of the
lyrics yeah i could would you mind it's
not too late the album's done and up and
out by now but we can always resubmit my
mind is just bubbling with possibilities
yeah i'm trying to think of what rhymes
with rooster how about 200 years before
he'd need his vax booster he was
attacked by an overzealous rooster you
can join the band because that's solid
incredible an incredible story and i
can't wait for all of you to enjoy
this song take us into it like a radio
dj
[Music]
you're listening to
kkkonm radio southern california's only
podcast great radio with your host
conan o'brien
all right well guess what that uh rockin
new band out of pasadena townland is
back and they have got a new wax platter
that we're gonna be spinning today this
is quite a song this one's dedicated to
elmer
ellsworth gourley and uh
we call this one
eyes or
give a listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't you
[Music]
lost tonight
[Music]
[Music]
he was
who could die
[Music]
[Music]
i've always had it
i've always had
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you got
[Music]
i'm a man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]